we stayed inside the first quarter take
with the real superpower all using the
unit circle is that ice and drove
straight out of there I think you're not
just from 0 up to 90 but I can get a few
tables over here and I'm going to
reflect angry lot even though none of
them can fit inside my right angle train
and this is what tells you that I mean
you guys are seen just a sec right
remember that
and see I want you to think about what
that means and why it makes sense if you
just think about these guys on building
circles of what an aiming but what for
safety platform which means what it
means all of the functions that you work
with sine and cos and tan they're all
positive well think about why tear cod
right why must cause them whatever then
here be positive
well because it's been excellent
right so everything in here is to the
right so all of the x coordinates are
positive
do you agree and even before you start
going around this way do you see that's
why this is see you see why that's sea
could look you're still talking about
x-coordinate and you're still to the
right side so that's why those all have
some fun okay we're outside what is
slime positive in this quadrant because
cited about a white corner right and
look on the bulbs and above the answer
steps up that's positive way we force or
explain why think in s to see what is
the death because I'm still above the
axis so the y-coordinate had still been
be positive right okay now our query
here down here in this quadrant tell me
about what kind of negative because the
x1 is on that negative side of the axis
right what about science also negative
because you're on the bottom which is
the Y corner so that's negative but then
of course we defined remember I said you
can call tan opposite on it
what a better definition for 10 is your
home
it's sign of the college right well if
both of these numbers are negative then
what happens when you divide thanks the
negative can when you get funded okay so
that's what this means it's just talking
about points on the circles and whether
you're horizontally positive or negative
or vertically positive or negative so
really really crispy let's just do an
example straight off with you
pick an angle any angle how about let's
see 102 you bet okay don't you die
greater add a new radius and when I'll
say a hundred fifty degrees I'm thinking
of introducing degrees I'm sorry
where am i starting my mission pro from
sodding County all right on the positive
x-axis I'm going to say that again and
again yes but get few months and then I
rotate any clockwise around okay is on
right now spread it out a little bit
weird because in the previous exercise I
don't know how far you got into it but
there are some various questions okay
of they're often very impressions now
various questions in the like this
bearing just on Turkey are witty very
subtle very something wrong with that
and there's from North which direction
you go in your clockwise like that right
but on here we're doing something really
different you start over here on that
side would be positive x-axis right and
then instead of measuring clockwise he
measure anti-clockwise okay so that's
weird
but it's an important distinction that I
want you to have in you have experience
a little better so we're done continue
to see 150 is on my diagram where would
you draw it you're doing him it's going
to stop here until you're all wear out
right so maybe you wanted to draw this
in with me that's going to continue
okay now help you work outside clothes
and tan of 150 degrees it helps to add
in that mine angle triangle which is
hiding like that do not see healthily
I'm fun she's my right angle so what
I've made over here is a new triangle
which has a radius cocky shot of one and
it's got a little acute angle easier
next to the negative x-axis religious
idea 30 degrees that's really good
because I believe that values Elena's
right
so in here
remember the coordinates of this spot
are costly decisive or superior choice
it was in in this case I went around
looking degree so therefore instead of
saying consider typing up are they cause
registry and sign hundred pieces now all
I need to know is how far away and how
high up and so have a seat
another thing maybe you want to label
with me this is the Y leg feel right
with the edge place where we put it can
we stand you up
I think the horizontal yes
that's why we're not running today okay
have a look inside this new triangle
with your right will decipher can you
tell me in this triangle what he is side
by side 30 is in that triangle opposite
on happens you agree that's what I said
over here why over 1 but you know what's
my venue thank you site that is a really
nice easy once remember it aha it's the
only noisy deal with the solar to rip
trees or anything like that so this is
simple so that boy so now I know that is
hot
what about this guy what true way sure
can I use with my face read that will
compare this guy to the one have a look
if adjacent right which is why is
because you fall in with me so even that
little triangle I think they caused 30
series equals adjacent and hypotenuse
remember that but hopefully we remember
what causes 30 degrees remember it's
going to be root 3 on 2 equals x now
just pause for a second over my diagram
I drew that X and a leg right so that's
going to correspond to this well just be
cat along the unit circle and over here
I went English direction to the left
right to the left foot X's me negative
right so this in fact he are the length
is root three on two
but the cool water that's our arms to
the right length the length is returned
to but the coordinate of this one is
negative return to that again negative
return to right this guy's glad to work
outside this is like 85 right because
you going up just polish so
that's that okay so tah-dah now I know
cause one disease is negative root 2 and
sine 150 is a huff of course you can
work out with camera cookies just from
those to you right now I'm going to do
it down here because we're about this
there's a half on Librium and Kapil's
negative root three on two on the
denominator so what happened what I do
this I can multiply the top of the
bottom by two which leads me I'll move
this negative as well maybe it won't
/ - okay are you happy to see how we do
that now you can do it by saying okay
130 is say memorize that sign is that
you put it in here that means causing
them to be negative and then sort of do
it with your asppb I think it's much
more helpful if you guys develop the
muscles think of where is this and what
does it mean to the sign to be let the
right up and down okay now let me know
about just with one extra tips get
contracted up because I don't want you
to rely find it method I'm about to show
you but I know what it's like when
you're first learning this and you're
like man is it three 300 or 103 or 100 -
I don't know they're all sort of
modeling in my hair
so here's a way you can check details
over there and we're just going to test
these one at a time but I'm going to
show you how to do it will do anything'
1/3 sine 150 okay so that's easy to test
950 and it hands back to you basically
exactly a half so so far so good
okay but thanks for the nice ones where
there are no Serbs right now keep
searching cause 150
you're good at you like gross okay now
because I've looked at this particular
number 0.866 ah blah blah blah blah I've
looked at hundreds of times well you
might have a fancy calculator okay so be
careful with that I won't come we have a
look at it again because I looked at
this number
I actually recognize this as root 3 on 2
okay but I wouldn't expect you to
so I want you to know two things out
number one it's negative is that what we
wanted it is like we're expecting a
negative number
okay now that actually check the value
all that I'm going to take this while
it's still in the display and I'm going
to square it so if you go answer squared
here hand you back 3/4 3/4 is that what
we all have supported yet if I squared
it do I get three clips in there - yes
okay so 0.866 whatever or 1.73 which is
root three or 1.41 or whatever which is
root 2 I don't expect you guys to
recognize that but your calculator it is
what they are so if you square it you
can very easily verify facts right then
we know one more time for this one
chocolate and 150 okay have a look at it
the first thing you look at is the sign
is the sign correct it's negative tick
okay and then to check that better 0.57
70 is what we think it is you square it
and it is your third is that what I want
do I Square this can get a certain F up
yes so anyway okay so that's kind of
handy as a check for you just so that
you have no doubt because I can
guarantee we're going to one my question
like this and if you remember the exact
ratio is wrong like when we're going
through this then maybe you'll get one
or two of those confused and you can
know you're in the right direction okay